E
THE WORDS DOMESTIC TERRORISM OR
PATRIOT ACT.
>> Bret: ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
THE HOT SEAT ON CAPITOL HILL
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
MEMO, INCREASING HARASSMENT AND
INTIMIDATION AND THREATS.
INSTRUCTED THE FBI TO WORK WITH
SCHOOL BOARDS.
"THE WASHINGTON FREE BEACON"
REPORTED THIS SPIRIT OF THE
COUNTRY'S LARGEST SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION COLLABORATED WITH
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE BEFORE
SENDING A CONTROVERSIAL LETTER
CALLING ON THE FBI TO
INVESTIGATE PARENTS AS POTENTIAL
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS ACCORDING TO
PREVIOUSLY UNRECORDED EMAILS.
THE LETTER MAKES CLEAR THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS AWARE OF THE
LETTER BEFORE IT WAS RELEASED
WHILE RAISING QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER THE WHITE HOUSE COLLUDED
WITH THE ASSOCIATION ON THE
LETTER TO PROMPT FEDERAL ACTION.
START WITH THE PANEL,
MARA LIASSON NATIONAL POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO, FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY ARI FLEISCHER, AND
KATIE PAVLICH.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS FROM THE
PUBLIC AND LAWMAKERS ON THAT
COMMITTEE TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, WHAT ABOUT THAT BACK
AND FORTH IN WHAT HE WAS SAYING.
>> TODAY IS A DAY I'M SO
GRATEFUL FOR MITCH McCONNELL
FOR KEEPING MERRICK GARLAND OFF
THE SUPREME COURT TO.
HE COMES ACROSS WITH SUCH
SOOTHING WORDS, NEVER IN A
MILLION YEARS WOULD WE EVER DO
THIS AND HE MEANWHILE IS VERY
POLITICAL BEHIND THE SCENES,
OTHERWISE WHY WOULD THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE EVER HAVE
ISSUED THAT LETTER IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
THEY HAVE TO BE AWARE THAT WHEN
YOU ARE TOLD SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
BE TREATED AS A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST AND THEN YOU SAY THE
FBI'S GOING TO LOOK INTO THIS
AND WE ARE GOING TO CONVENE
MEETINGS WITH U.S. ATTORNEYS
WITHIN 30 DAYS OF RECEIPT OF
THIS LETTER, THEY MEAN ACTION.
HE CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
IT WAS NOT A GOOD DAY FOR
IMPARTIAL, NONPARTISAN JUSTICE
AND HE NEVER HEARD ABOUT THE
INSURRECTION THAT TOOK PLACE
LAST WEEK AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE INTERIOR, WHERE CLIMATE
ACTIVISTS, 55 OF WHOM GOT
ARRESTED INTO THE POLICE TO
OCCUPY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR?
HE SAID HE NEVER HEARD OF IT.
THAT WAS REPORTED IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST," REPORTED
BY MSNBC, BY FOX, AND BY THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS, HOW COULD HE
NOT HAVE KNOWN?
>> Bret: THERE IS ANOTHER
EXCHANGE ON THAT SCHOOL BOARD
LETTER.
>> ONE OF THE WORRIES THAT I
HAVE ABOUT THE WAY THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT RACE IS THAT IT
EITHER SEEMS SO BIG THAT --
>> JUSTICE DEPARTMENT COMMITTEE
CATES WITH THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
PRIOR TO THE LETTER.
DID YOU HELP THE NATIONAL SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION PUT TOGETHER
THE LETTER?
>> I HAVE HAD NO SUCH
CONVERSATIONS, I WOULD BE
SURPRISED IF THAT HAPPENED BUT I
DON'T KNOW.
>> WHEN DID YOU FIRST REVIEW THE
DATA SHOWING THIS SO-CALLED
DISTURBING UPTICK.
>> I READ THE LETTER AND WE HAVE
BEEN SEEING OVER TIME THREATS --
>> I DID ASK YOU -- YOU READ THE
LETTER, THAT IS A RESOURCE?
>> FROM THE NATIONAL SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION WITH
REPRESENTS THOUSANDS OF SCHOOL
BOARDS AND SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
SAYS THERE ARE THESE KINDS OF
THREATS.
>> Bret: OBVIOUSLY
CONDOLEEZZA RICE WASN'T THE
HEARING.
JIM JORDAN PRESSING ON WHAT WAS
THE INITIATION AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAYING IT WAS
THAT LETTER.
>> THE NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION APPEARS TO BE
REPORTING THAT THERE IS THIS
UPTICK OF THREATS, IT'S THE JOB
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
LOOK INTO THINGS THAT COULD BE A
CRIME.
ACTS OF VIOLENCE, NOT PROTESTS
AS MERRICK GARLAND SAID OR ANY
KIND OF FREEDOM OF SPEECH RIGHTS
THAT ARE EXERCISED AT THE SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS.
WILL NOT WAIT AND SEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DOES BUT
THE REPUBLICANS ON THE PANEL ARE
CLEARLY TRYING TO SAY THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO BE GOING AFTER
PARENTS AND SQUELCHING THEIR
FREE SPEECH RIGHTS.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE TIMELINE
OF THIS, THE WHITE HOUSE DID
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF THIS LETTER
DAYS BEFORE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE CAME OUT WITH THEIR MEMO
AND MERRICK GARLAND SAID TODAY
THE MEMO THEY RELEASED HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH DOMESTIC
TERRORISM AND THE PATRIOT ACT.
BUT THE LETTER FROM THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL BOARDS DID USE THAT
LANGUAGE, DID ASK THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO DO THAT, IT WAS
GIVEN TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
ADDRESSED TO PRESIDENT BIDEN IN
A FEW DAYS LATER COINCIDENTALLY,
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
RELEASES THE MEMO SAYING THEY'RE
GOING TO KEEP A CLOSER EYE ON
THIS DESPITE THE FACT THEY
HAVEN'T INVESTIGATED WHETHER
THESE ARE FEDERAL CRIMES OR NOT.
THEY SIMPLY GOT THIS LETTER.
THE BROADER QUESTION HERE IS,
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID HE WANTED
AN INDEPENDENT JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THE SEQUENCE OF EVENTS HERE
DOESN'T INDICATE THAT AND MORE
BROADLY SPEAKING, THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE UNDER DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT HAS A HISTORY OF GOING
AFTER POLITICAL OPPONENTS AND
USING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO DO
THAT WHETHER IT WAS IRS
TARGETING OF TEA PARTY GROUPS IN
2010, WHETHER IT WAS THE FBI
GOING AFTER TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS AND GETTING AN ILLEGAL
WARRANT TO SPY ON CARTER PAGE.
THIS IS A QUESTION WHETHER THE
PART OF JUSTICE IS GOING TO DO
ON BEHALF OF THE WHITE HOUSE TO
GET AHEAD POLITICALLY.
>> Bret: A COUPLE THINGS BUT
HEARING, THE AG SAYING THEY WILL
CONSIDER THE ATTEMPT THAT'S
VOTED ON IN THE HOUSE AGAINST
STEVE BANNON, AND THAT THE DURUM
INVESTIGATION IS IN FACT
CONTINUING AND IS FULLY FUNDED
AS H